revenu à chaux-neuve émission spéciale
ce matin dans dimanche en politique sur
france 3 bourgogne franche comté
nous sommes dans le haut doubs à
quelques kilomètres du département du
jura quelques kilomètres de la suisse et
si nous avons choisi de faire cette
émission spéciale c'est parce que se
déroule dans ce petit village de 2 300
habitants
une coupe du monde de combiné nordique
la mecque du combiné nordique en france
c'est chaux-neuve alors à quoi cela
sert-il de miser sur des événements
comme celui-là d'investir dans des
grandes compétitions
est-ce que cela a des retombées
positives sur le grand public est ce que
ça attire des touristes sur l'ensemble
du massif du jura c'est la question
qu'on va se poser en direct avec nos
invités à nos invités que je vous
présente tout de suite d'abord
marie-guite dufay présidente du conseil
régional de bourgogne franche comté
également sur ce plateau à nicolas
michaud le directeur du centre national
de ski nordique de prémanon à quelques
kilomètres d'ici et puis michel vion
président de la fédération française de
ski merci à tous les trois d'être venu
sur ce plateau alors vous en avez
l'habitude cette émission c'est aussi la
vôtre vous pouvez interpeller nos
invités leur poser vos questions je mens
frère le relais tout au long de cette
émission vos questions vous pouvez les
poser sur la page internet de notre
émission sur le site de france 3
bourgogne franche comté et puis vous
pouvez aussi commenter l'émission sur
les réseaux sociaux avec le mot diez qui
s'affiche dit mme paul bfc comme
dimanche en politique en bourgogne
franche comté
alors madame messieurs 4000 spectateurs
environ hier pour la course individuelle
de combiné nordique ont les
organisateurs attendent encore plus de
monde aujourd'hui pour l'épreuve de
relais qui se déroulera en tout début
d'après-midi fait revenir dans ce coin
du haut doubs l'élite mondiale
finalement d'un sport comme le combiné
nordique nicolas michaud je me tourne
vers vous c'est à chaque fois un petit
exploit
ouais c'est assez incroyable c'est vrai
que c'est un village de 200 habitants et
elle et les équipes étrangères en
arrivant ici les premières années se
demandait
mais on fait une coupe du monde ici et
après ils sont impressionnés finalement
pendant l'événement du nombre de
spectateurs delà de la ferveur qui a ici
et c'est vraiment génial et c'est vrai
quand on regarde le calendrier des
coupes du monde
on voit des noms prestigieux comme oslo
comme mme latifa des grosses villes et
on a dans la même liste on à chaux neuve
est et c'est vrai que c'est assez
ça c'est beau de voir ça et c'est
maintenant une d une des plus belles
épreuves
ça apporte quoi massif du jura une
épreuve comme celle-là ça vraiment là
pour l'image en tout cas du nordic déjà
parce que c'est vrai qu'on a on est un
pays nordiques on a essayé de ski
nordique et de faire des épreuves de ce
niveau là sur sur d'autres massifs
je crois vraiment que ça à sa porte
cette image et que et que cela c'est une
belle image en tout cas que peut montrer
la franche-comté marie-guite dufay les
collectivités locales le conseil
régional et d'autres collectivités
investissent accompagne ce genre
d'événement parce que cela participe à
la notoriété de la région du massif côté
on serait complètement en dehors de nos
de nos responsabilités à côté de nos
responsabilités si on accompagnait pas
l'excellence et l'excellence ici elle se
nomme combiné nordique biathlon
il faut accompagner cet excellent c'est
une ardente obligation qui effectivement
nous a amené des investissements
importants mais ce qui est absolument
significatif c'est que ce sont des
investissements de toutes les
collectivités la région le département
du doubs le département du jura
on n'est pas dans le département du jura
mais le département du jura a apporté
aussi sa cote pas parce qu'il ya
vraiment ici un esprit massif et quand
vous dites qu'est ce que ça apporte
c'est vrai que déjà on a des images
extraordinaires c'est comme quand le
tour de france vient et on les voit
justement l'antenne la ferveur du public
viendrait la météo âge dit si elle
partait je pense que les gens qui
viennent qui découvre son envie de
revenir mais pas forcément l'hiver
découvrir aussi ce territoire mais ce
qu'il ya c'est qui a la beauté du
paysage
il ya la force de la compétition mais
vous savez il ya surtout la beauté des
hommes et des femmes parce que cette
mobilisation qui est ici c'est
typiquement une mobilisation
si du massif c'est l'esprit d'ici et
c'est ça qu'on veut aussi avec des
centaines devaient révéler cet esprit de
coopération de savoir travailler
ensemble de savoirs se mobiliser pour
réaliser un exploit chaux-neuve
effectivement au centre du monde du
combiné nordique c'est un exploit il l'a
réussi
michel vion vous confirmez chaux neuve
c'est un rendez vous incontournable
aujourd'hui sur la planète combiné
nordique hier le vainqueur le leader de
la coupe du monde le norvégien jan
schmid disait c'est incroyable montrent
qu'il ya sur le bord de la piste oui
c'est ça qui lequel est comment dire le
symbole fabrique de chaux neuve c'est un
public extraordinaire
donc il ya 7 et 10 par nicolas il ya une
semaine une tradition massif jurassien
terre de champions et l'ordi qu'à une
vraie histoire ici et si près c'est pour
la raison pour laquelle on a cette
épreuve ici elle est par ailleurs elle
est ici dans le massif du jura
parce qu'on pense que c'est la meilleure
place pour avoir une épreuve de grande
renommée mondiale alors néanmoins on va
pas se mentir le combiné nordique ça
reste une discipline relativement
confidentiel on en a beaucoup parlé dans
les médias il ya quelques années quand
jason lamy chappuis était haut au sommet
de la discipline
la maintenance est peut-être plus
compliqué il ya yannick là sur les
réseaux sociaux qui nous dit oui une
politique événementielle évidemment
c'est un gage de promotion de
développement territorial mais quand
même
ce n'est que du combiné nordique entre
guillemets
marie-guite dufay oui mais je vous dise
et c'est l'esprit c'est la beauté du
massif qui est en jeu aussi
ainsi je pense que véritablement ce qui
se passe ici en matière de compétition
est un facteur d'attractivité pour notre
massive pour faire venir des gens parce
que déjà tous ceux qui viennent pour la
coupe du monde
ils ont vite revenir l'été que les
images qui sont colportées ce sont des
images qui donnent envie de venir et
c'est vrai que nous misons beaucoup sur
cette force sur cette excellence pour
bâtir toute une politique d'attractivité
touristique à et ça prendra parce que le
tourisme augmente on y travaille
moi ce que je regrette c'est plutôt au
niveau de la pratique du ski c'est à
dire que je vois bien je parle même pas
du combiné nordique mais du ski de ski
nordique de ski de fond aujourd'hui
c'est presque trop l'ama l'apanage dans
l'esprit des gens de la compétition
alors que c'est absolument
extraordinaire de chausser les skis puis
de partir par monts et par vaux sans
aucun esprit de compétition tellement on
a un paradis pour cela et il ya quelque
chose qu'on a encore à faire là pour
pousser à ce que ça soit une pratique
plus populaire après enfin nicolas
michaud nous le confirmera mais par
exemple je suis allé en reportage à la
darbella à côté de l'amour à ya quelques
jours en début de semaine il y avait à
la fois des sportifs des vrais sportifs
qui se préparait et puis il y avait à la
fois vraiment les amateurs qui
découvrent et découvrez le fond nicolas
michaud vous confirmer il ya aussi une
pratique d'amateurs sur le bassiste
c'est clair il ya un terrain de jeu qui
était formidable assure sur tout le
massif il ya des centaines de kilomètres
de pistes de fond dans la nature au
milieu de la forêt est en tout cas cet
hiver notamment avec l'arrivée de la
neige en volonté par rapport aux années
d'avant on a vu beaucoup beaucoup de
skieurs de fond amateurs y compris hors
saison pas forcément qu'à noël ou en
février là en tout cas hors saison là on
était assez surpris de voir le nombre de
gens qui qui se remettent au ski de fond
donc c'est vrai qu'il faut qu'il y ait
de l'année des bonnes conditions et est
notre terrain de jeu est magnifique
michel vion est-ce que néanmoins le ski
nordique reste pas le parent vaut le
parent pauvre des disciplines du ski
c'est l'alpin la vitrine
alors ça c'est une très mauvaise
question parce qu'il fallut tout ce
qu'on pourrait croire effectivement qu
on est parent pauvre
non ya pas de parent pauvre il ya des
disciplines sont différentes il ya un
monde économique lié au tour au tour de
ceux du ski alpin qui est bien supérieur
c'est une évidence
néanmoins le ski nordique est important
pour nous fédération en tout cas on est
on est attaché à ce que les pratiquants
soit soit comment dire actifs
et puis c'est un gros pourvoyeur de
médailles aussi là il
prépare tous les jeux pour l'améliorer
hier les médailles à la clé mais aussi
des grandes épreuves populaires comme
transjurassienne par exemple oulaï c'est
du sport de masse et ça c'est important
d'avoir aussi dans une phase le lien
entre le public le loisir et la
compétition marié du fait vous pointiez
vous mettiez l'accent sur le sport
populaire
mais quand jason lamy chappuis gagnent
des médailles quand là on va attendre
aussi quentin fillon mallet où anaïs
bescond sur sur le biathlon
quand des athlètes franc comtois brille
ça ramène aussi du grand public sur le
massif c'est important aussi je crois
qu'ils se rangent les athlètes
il ya une image il ya une image
d'excellence et c'est l'excellence
jurassienne au sens le massif du jura
donc il ya l'excellence de nos
compétiteurs de nos sportifs dans un
contexte d'excellence aussi économique à
parce que le massif du jura
c'est quand même l'excellence en matière
agricole ya aucun autre endroit en
france où les éleveurs sont heureux du
travail qu'ils font et arrive à bien se
rémunérer c'est ici
grâce à l'organisation une organisation
coopérative donc c'est aussi cet esprit
là et j'insiste vraiment cette capacité
à se mobiliser à travailler ensemble à à
coopérer c'est celle-là même d'ici et je
pense que c'est un facteur
d'attractivité
alors on parlait du combiné mais aussi
pour le biathlon le massif du jura est
une référence
il ya des athlètes qui brille et puis il
ya aussi le centre de pré banon qui est
aujourd'hui la référence pour la
préparation des athlètes et du matériel
nicolas michaud évidemment vous pouvez
nous en parler
et puisqu'on sait pas par exemple c'est
que martin fourcade à un mois des jeux
il vient passer ses vacances de noël et
du réveillon
ici à prémanon pour se préparer pour la
compétition la plus importante d
des années qui viennent pas c'est clair
en fait il ya une entente assez
incroyable entre les collectivités la
fédération qui a souhaité installer son
centre national d'entraînement après
manon et on est un outil magnifique
maintenant qui va encore évoluer avec
avec des travaux encore son stade et tu
es bien sûr que maintenant avec un outil
pareil
les athlètes de plus en plus viennent
s'entraîner à et vous l'avez dit martin
fourcade a fait dix jours il est venu
passer noël nouvel an après manon vient
chercher chez vous ben hilli à chercher
des équipements des entraîneurs du du
personnel c'est à dire que le matin il
pouvait il avait son entraîneur pour les
sur le stade de biathlon directement
s'entraîner l'après midi vous l'avez dit
partez sur la darbella et parcourir des
centaines de kilomètres il avait une
salle de musculation dans l'eau dans
notre notre établissement du coup voilà
il retrouve la totalité le soir des
kinés des austin qui viennent aussi
travaillé chez nous dans le centre
d'entraînement
donc c'est un le mot je prends
importance et centres d'entraînement
il ya une expertise mais extraordinaire
dans ce centre avec une recherche
constante pour innover en matière de
matériaux oui c'est ça c'est à dire que
entraînement au pense entraînement
humain mais qu'il ya aussi tout le
matériel tout l'environnement
technologique qui est travaillé à ses
vrais sont liés dont six avec avec les
collectivités à la région de
franche-comté qui nous apporte des
moyens toutes les cabines de bateau par
exemple son travail et à prémanon dans
un local spécifique avec des machines
avec franck gadio qui est un qui est un
personnel de l'établissement et la
fédération est donc tout est travaillé
spécifiquement la la glisse aussi font
la bise du ski de fond les camions de
sauvetage qui sont bien compris cela et
combinaisons qui seront mises en dessous
qui sont qui sont fabriqués par une
couturière au sein de notre
établissement est donc ça ça vient en
appui de la fédération et c'est ça nous
permet aussi de ne pas dépendre des
marques et d'avoir des outils
spécifiques développées pour nos
athlètes
michel vion vous qui n'êtes pas franc
comtois prémanon c'est connu en dehors
de la
la franche comté cette référence pour le
ski nordique en france ont encore niveau
de la france est certain c'est reconnu
par ministère des sports c'est d'abord
ça établissement d'état mais dans la
salle expertise ça a été dit un instant
dans les fertilisants ont fait partie
des abysses mans qui sont haut de gamme
et reconnu comme tel et le fait d'avoir
mis notre centre national d'entraînement
basé à prémanon c'est c'est la meilleure
preuve encore une fois on est on est
pris en exemple un nombreuses occasions
alors nicolas michaud l'a évoqué les
travaux en ce moment à prémanon parce
que prémanon a été choisie pour
accueillir dans le cadre d'une
candidature suisse
les épreuves de nordique des jeux
olympiques de la jeunesse ce sera en
2020 nicolas michaud ça c'est un énorme
événement pour pour vous vous êtes
d'ailleurs responsable du site pour pour
cette épreuve là oui c'est un gros
événement il faut le dire ce sera la
seule occasion de d'abord les anneaux
olympiques sur la franche comté sur le
haut jura il faut être très clair
donc c'est un gros événement ses 1800
athlètes c'est 70 nations toutes les
disciplines nordiques donc feront les
compétitions à prémanon
et donc on fait évoluer le stade pour
pour être de niveau on va dire pour ces
compétitions mais aussi pour laisser un
héritage d'équipement on l'a dit pour
nos athlètes pour les 20 ans et 30 ans
qui viennent et ça ça nous positionne
vraiment en tout cas pour l'avenir avec
des équipements de pointe et donc voilà
les jeux olympiques de la jeunesse c'est
vraiment les standards du cio c'est le
standard des jeux à la différence que
c'est des athlètes juniors au lieu des
athlètes seniors
donc c'est un symbole un gros événement
et je pense que la franche comté va
essayer de faire vivre cet événement me
oui michel vion vous confirmer c'est
vraiment une compétition premier plan
les jeux olympiques de la jeunesse c'est
pas forcément connus du grand public
parce que c'est assez récent mais
vraiment c'est du très haut niveau
c'est pas très connue c'est vrai mais
c'est cet héliport nicolas c'est d'abord
et avant tout les anneaux olympiques qui
sont comment dire donner aux territoires
et ça pour moi c'est très important
et puis surtout c'est pas pour moi
l'événementiel qui soit pour les jeunes
joueuses appuie la jeunesse ou coupe du
monde ici à chaux neuve c'est s'il
fallait se payer l'équivalent
l'équivalent en promotion comment dire
en images ça serait possible donc
célébrer l'événement c'est la vitrine
d'un mur vitrine qui peut avoir une
région un territoire où un massif
donc encore une fois c'est tout ce qu'on
peut mettre on y en eut même marie-guite
dufay les collectivités ont été
sollicités
pour ces travaux il ya 6 millions
d'euros investis alors les collectivités
françaises mais aussi les collectivités
suisses en franche-comté évidemment on
connaît le massif du jura maintenant
qu'on est une grande région
est-ce que c'est facile de convaincre
vos collègues bourguignon d'investir sur
prémanon par exemple aucun problème
parce que les bourguignons qui sont
conscients de tout le potentiel qu'ils
ont sur leur territoire savent très bien
qu'ils n'ont pas de montagne ils ont le
morvan mais le morvan et quand même
guerre enneigées oui et le réflexe des
bourguignons c'est vraiment d'aller sur
le massif du jura dès que les premiers
flocons arrivent et vous pouvez le
constater dans les hébergements ici les
bourguignons sont nombreux donc c'est
surtout par un sujet cela alors
justement vous parlez d'enneigement ya
cécile qui nous pose une question qui
est un peu récurrentes sur le massif du
jura
quand on évoque à quoi ça sert
d'investir dans des événements comme
celui-là ll nous dit bas à quoi bon vu
l'enneigement qui est aléatoire pas
toujours au rendez vous et vu le coût
des investissements
est-ce que qu'est ce que vous répondez à
ces gens nombreux aussi qui doutent de
la pertinence de ses investissements là
qu'il faut quand même faire attention on
a une vraie richesse c'est vrai qu'il y
à des aléas climatiques qui sont de plus
en plus nombreux et qui pèse sur
l'exploitation des stations et donc il
faut faire en sorte que les stations
puisse offrir une diversité d'activités
et ne pas miser uniquement sur la neige
mais on ne peut pas tourner le dos à la
neige c'est consubstantiel à notre
identité à notre nature il ya aussi
énormément de touristes il faut le dire
les t notes sur le mât sur l'ensemble du
massif du jura
parce que c'est aussi magnifique c'est
pour ça que tous les investissements que
nous faisons sur les stations que ça
soit les roues ce que ça soit métabief
sont vraiment conditionnée au fait qu'on
développe un tourisme quatre saisons à
ce pas simplement un tourisme d'hiver
aller ils nous écoutent attentivement
depuis le début de l'émission on va
demander à julien laurent de france bleu
besançon notre partenaire pour ce
week-end de fête du combiné nordique à
chaux-neuve de nous rejoindre
bonjour julien vous aviez une question
en or on va dire pour nos invités en
question alors j'ai écouté attentivement
effectivement nicolas qui le disaient
ces fameux jeux olympiques de la
jeunesse vont être là
l'occasion d'avoir les anneaux
olympiques ici dans le massif jurassien
mais est-ce que à terme
lausanne l'a dit qu'ils organisent donc
ces jeux olympiques de la jeunesse en
2020 c'est peut-être une répétition
générale pour eux un souhait d'avoir les
vrais granger aux divers est ce qu'un
partenariat toujours avec le massif
jurassien serait possible je te
demanderai associé à michel vion bonne
question je crois pas je crois pas que
lausanne est en tête d'être une
répétition pour des grands jeux
olympiques en 2000 26 par exemple la
suisse est candidat comme vous le savez
avec affection le valais c'est pas gagné
encore mais effectivement ils sont
candidats
je ne crois pas qu'il ya un lien direct
entre lausanne 2020 pour les jeunes avec
2026 éventuellement le valais mais là où
ça ira ça ira bien sûr néanmoins michel
vion quand lausanne a eu les jeux
olympiques de la jeunesse
l'un des membres l'un des cinq membres
suisse du cio a dit lausanne réfléchi
très concrètement une candidature pour
les jeux d'hiver 2026 ou 2030 c'est pas
voilà ils ont affiché leurs ambitions
alors ce n'est qu'a affiché ses
ambitions mais mais néanmoins il ya un
il ya une promesse qui est fait là sauf
que de la pluie sauf que depuis
effectivement si on sait que c'est aussi
des officiellement voilà comme lady
michelle je pense qu'aujourd'hui n'y a
pas eu de discussion là dessus et je
pense que c'est pas c'est pas l'ordre du
jour ce qu'il faut souligner le
président du cio l'a souligné quand il
ya eu la candidature de lausanne qui a
été reçu c2c ce projet transfrontalier
des joj
et c'est la première fois que ça existe
dans le monde des djo et de le président
thomas ce bord du cio l'a dit dans les
candidatures futur il souhaiterait
déconnade des candidatures frontalière
entre plusieurs pays l'italie la
slovénie l'autriche qui sont des fois un
peu ensemble et est donc je crois que ce
qu'on fait là sont les joj c'est quand
même une première qui va découler
peut-être sur des candidatures jiho
transfrontalière la discussion
aujourd'hui avec alors pas les patriotes
d'accord pas tout de suite peut-être un
jour en revanche des championnats du
monde de ski nordique dont ce massif
jurassien est ce que la france
on aa les championnats du monde de ski
alpin qui va arriver bientôt michel vion
mais est ce qu'on peut se positionner
aussi on sait qu'il ya toute notre
structure on l'a dit après manon à chaux
neuve
voilà val di fiemme il ya en 2013 on a
accueilli on voit qu'il ya pas beaucoup
de monde a beaucoup d'hébergement ce
c'est jouable a priori pour être franc
avec vous on y réfléchit alors on est
candidat pour 2023 pour le ski alpin
donc on peut pas mener de front
différentes candidatures en tout cas ce
qui est certain que s'il y avait un jour
une voiture française pour le nordique
ça peut être que dans le jura c'est ça
c'est très clair après il ya pas
uniquement les installations il faut
aussi avoir tout tout tout d'un accueil
les bains un hébergement c'est ça
dépasse le cadre sportif
mais encore une fois c'est on peut
réfléchir à ce genre de ce genre de
chose en terme d'équipement en termes de
l'histoire en termes de savoir faire
d'expérience on a tout ce qu'il faut
après enfin d'infrastructures hôtelières
il faudra effectivement être un peu plus
un peu plus solide à quel horizon
cinquantaine d'années série c'est une
dizaine d'années ces dizaines d'années
donc on revit chez desjardins m23 donc
on est déjà c'est en avance mais sur sur
27 sur 29 pourquoi pas si ça peut être
une bonne idée
marie-guite dufay vous confirmer c'est
au niveau des infrastructures notamment
hôtelière que aujourd'hui ça met un peu
à 20 parfaitement
nous nous sommes donné une très très
grande ambition en matière de tourisme
au niveau de la région et dans cette
ambition il ya de vraiment la montée en
gamme en matière d'hébergement montée en
gamme et quantitatifs et qualitatifs en
manque
on manque d'hôtels au manque de gîtes et
donc nous on est prêt à investir on a
des procédures d'intervention
il faut que ce sont d'abord des enfants
des initiatives particulières oui il
faut que de l'investissement privé et à
partir du moment où vient cet
investissement privé on est prêt à le
soutenir et elle soutenir largement aux
lions ne demande que cela
parce qu'effectivement on peut pas faire
venir les touristes si on sait pas les
accueillir correctement et on manque
vraiment que c'est pas le serpent qui se
mord un peu la queue c'est à dire que
les particuliers les initiatives privées
sont aujourd'hui timide parce que elles
ont peut-être peur de pas avoir la la
clientèle suffisante
bah peut-être mais c'est à nous de
convaincre aussi est de montrer grâce à
cette attractivité grandissante que le
marché est là le potentiel est là
parce que et
vient manifestement la possibilité
d'investir mais c'est compliqué c'est
compliqué à le métier d'investisseur
touristique
donc moi je comprends que chacun se pose
des questions mais c'est à nous au
niveau des collectivités de montrer qu
on est vraiment très allants et qu'on
est prêt à faire le maximum à partir du
moment où des investisseurs privés
arrive
j'ai livré finalement c'est l'image de
marque dont on parle depuis lé début
d'émission finalement ici depuis des
années qui est bien établie dans le
massif jurassien ici à chaux neuve qui
doit pousser alors on veut pas voir
recommander de faire quoi que ce soit
évidemment au niveau des collectivités
n'y a pas que les collectivités vous
l'avais dit au niveau des particuliers
également mais ça serait dommage de
passes surfer entre guillemets sur cette
toile de quêtes bien implantée depuis
des années et des années ici ça fait
partie vraiment des priorités qu'on
s'est donné au niveau de la région avec
toutes les autres collectivités a foncé
sur l'hébergement l'améliorer faire en
sorte que l'offre soit beaucoup plus au
rendez vous nicolas michaud dans
l'impression le monde sportif jurassien
essaie aussi de alors on a compris un
léger au voile à mes essais de montée en
gamme les compétitions progressivement
pour justement prouvé sa capacité à
organiser
oui il faut être assez progressif un
euro ont fait pas des compétitions de
tout haut niveau comme ça il ya
plusieurs épreuves à faire et des
épreuves juniors il ya des épreuves de
coupe d'europe pour arriver après sur
des gros événements donc donc on y
travaille surpris mais non il y aura
maintenant des nouvelles compétitions de
biathlon international junior dès
décembre l'année prochaine il y aura une
à priori c'est encore officielle mais
une coupe du monde de saut dames et on
l'a dit aussi on n'a pas dit d'ailleurs
sont les joj
on aura une première épreuve qui sera le
combiné nordique féminin est donc ce
sera les premières médailles décernées à
des féminines en combiné nordique
parce qu'il faut le rappeler les joj
sont aussi pour le co2 laboratoire des
vrais jeux des jeux traditionnels et
donc ils essayent les disciplines et les
formats sur les joj
je viens en aide montée en gamme on l'a
vu notamment cette année avec cette
épreuve de relais dont pour la première
fois depuis 1996 ici à chaux neuve en
coupe du monde donc on monte en gamme on
monte en gamme et puis aussi ici c'est
la preuve du savoir faire de shawn heins
finalement est-ce que à terme on va
encore pouvoir monter en gamme au niveau
de deux des compétitions proposées parmi
les plus belles de du circuit mondial de
combinés roddick oui mais on l'a dit
c'est déjà une redire c'est déjà une
compétition qui est dans le top 3 on
peut le dire des coupes du monde de
combiné nordique est et on l'a vu ce
week-end avec des conditions super
difficile
c'est énorme le travail qu'elle fournit
à la qualité du travail qui fournit la
fise l'a dit hier avec des conditions
comme ça il ya certains endroits avec
peu de bénévoles ou pas de compétences
qu'on aurait pu mettre les compétitions
annulée et du coup la lah fils d'acier
en dix ans avec des conditions pareilles
on n'en revient pas que l'organisateur
arrive à sortir au niveau de qualité de
compétition donc on peut dire que le
niveau de compétition les qualités de la
compétition elle est déjà là après il
faut rester toujours au standard c'est à
dire que les fédérations internationales
des fois ajoute des choses dans les
standards il faut rester après
respectivement tandis que la fif pouces
l'organisation ici à chanel de montée en
gamme
je crois qu'ils ont monté en gamme il ya
un standard minimum mais on fait partie
des ddd coupe du monde qui sont déjà
standard assez haut mais la fif nous
fait vraiment confiance dans la mesure
où l'année prochaine on peut le dire
clairement
ils nous ont sollicités pour accueillir
le triple tripple ces trois épreuves
samedi dimanche avec un mini tour entre
guillemets et ce mini tour donc il est
proposé acquis à chaux neuve et on va
l'accepter parce que c'est un énorme
challenge pour nous toujours cette
montée en gamme et c'est rarissime
ce qu'il faut dire c'est et renvoie là
c'est le tour voilà c'est ça donc encore
une fois c'est le standard nous permet
maintenant de dire on en peut être
candidat il y accueillir ce genre
d'épreuve rendre une fois pour moi c'est
une vitrine formidable pour pour un
massif qui voilà qui est dynamique a
besoin de bouger et moi qui j'ai pas du
tout du massif comme vous le savez
pouvaient être fiers et mentalement de
ce qu'est ce qui fait qu'on a des coupes
du monde comme nordique connu au monde
de saut à skis pour féminin les joj dans
deux ans ça c'est des événements qui
aiment les lignes qu'il faut utiliser
ces femmes arrêt qui tu fais la
bourgogne franche comté est fier de son
bas si j'allais dire c'est un combiné
d'are allez dire ça ce qui se passe ici
est absolument rare il faut vraiment que
les les habitants de cette région en
soient fiers et archi fier et en tout
cas moi je suis heureuse quand je vous
entends le président de la fédération de
ski parce que vous êtes totalement
convaincu je suis pas sûr il ya quelques
années et c'est normal quand vous êtes
arrivé vous vous êtes dit ici son sen
passe bien
un gars ya de l'engouement mais on
sentait qu'il fallait quand même qu'on
vous convaincre et là c'est fait donc
vraiment je suis très heureux et bien
écoutez ce sera le mot de la fin merci à
tous les quatre d'avoir participé à
cette émission
la coupe du monde de combiné nordique
continue évidemment sur france3 bourg
franche comté rendez-vous à 12h45 pour
les épreuves de saut en direct sur le
site internet de france 3 bourgogne
franche comté et à partir de 15h pour la
course en relais ça c'est sur internet
et puis à 20h30 émission spéciale pour
revivre ce dimanche de fête du combiné
aujourd'hui à chaux neuve sur notre
antenne sur france 3 bourgogne franche
comté à partir de 20h30
et puis vous l'avez compris il y aura
trois jours de fête du combiné nordique
l'an prochain ici à chaux neuve et le
président de la fédération nous a
annoncé qu'on réfléchisse et
éventuellement d'ici une dizaine
d'années à accueillir des championnats
du monde de ski nordique dans un instant
dimanche en politique continue avec la
ministre des armées et florence parly
qui sera l'invité de francis letellier
ce sera juste après votre flash
d'information sur france 3 bourgogne et
france 3 franche comté et puis la
semaine prochaine france 3 mobilisent à
nouveau ses antennes pour vous faire
vivre au plus près les événements de la
région
avec la saint vincent tournante dans le
mâconnais avec les lions veulent et bon
dimanche à tous
[Musique]